LITTLE DONNY HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SO SPECIAL TO US.
HE'S GOT AN ENTHUSIASM
YOU CAN'T FIND ANYWHERE ELSE.
YOU THINK YOU'VE
GOT PROBLEMS,
AND THEN YOU SEE DONNY
AND WHAT HE HAS TO DEAL WITH,
AND THE WAY HE'S ALWAYS
FULL OF JOY AND HAPPINESS,
AND HE'S SO OPEN
TO PEOPLE.
IT PUTS THINGS
IN PERSPECTIVE.
OH, DONNY'S GREAT.
VERY BRIGHT.
SOMETIMES HE GETS SAD WHEN HE
SEES THE KIDS IN THE PLAYGROUND
AND HE'S
STUCK IN INSIDE.
BUT GENERALLY,
HE'S A REALLY HAPPY KID.
DONNY HAS MORE HEART THAN
MOST ATHLETES TWICE HIS SIZE.
I JUST WANT DONNY
TO BE HAPPY,
TO FIND SOMEBODY
WHO'LL LOVE HIM.
TO BE ABLE TO FIT IN
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE.
WHAT I WANT FOR DONNY IS
FREEDOM TO BE A NORMAL KID.
I'LL DO ANYTHING TO
HELP HIM GET THROUGH LIFE
WITHOUT THE DISABILITY
INFRINGING ON
HIS ABILITY
TO ENJOY LIFE.
THIS HOLIDAY SEASON,
THE LITTLE DONNY FOUNDATION
IS ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
WITH YOUR HELP, WE HOPE TO CURE
"LITTLE DONNY DISEASE"
BEFORE ANOTHER CHILD LIKE DONNY
BECOMES AFFLICTED WITH:
A PENIS THE SIZE
OF A HORSE'S.
DONNY IS THE FIRST
DOCUMENTED CASE
OF WHAT WE HAVE LABELED,
MAGNAMOUS OBLIVIO PHALLUSITIS,
IN LAYMAN'S TERMS,
HAVING AN ENORMOUS PENIS
WHICH YOU ARE UNAWARE OF.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
SAFETY DEVICES I'VE DEVELOPED
TO HELP DONNY LEAD
A MORE NORMAL LIFE.
I HAVE TO SAY, I DON'T
LIKE THESE DEVICES.
I THINK THEY CALL ATTENTION
TO HIS DISEASE.
THEY MAKE HIM
FEEL DIFFERENT.
AND, HIS PENIS IS
REALLY NOT THAT BIG.
HIS PENIS ACCOUNTS FOR OVER
13% OF HIS TOTAL BODY WEIGHT.
WE DON'T NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THIS--
MOMMY, I GOT A
CHOCOLATE MILK MUSTACHE !
WE'RE GONNA SHOW THESE GUYS
SOME DEVICES I'VE DEVELOPED.
NO !
COME ON, DONNY.
YES.
NOT ALL THE DEVICES HAVE BEEN
AS SUCCESSFUL AS I HOPED.
THIS IS CALLED
A "PENIS STRAP",
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT
IT CAUSED SOME CHAFING--
NO !
TO HOLD THE PENIS DOWN,
YOU HAVE TO CINCH IT TIGHT.
OW !
IT'S ALMOST OVER,
SWEETIE.
OKAY, OKAY.
I GOTTA GET HIM.
UMM...
DONNY REALLY LIKES
CHOCOLATE MILK.
I LOVE
LITTLE DONNY,
'CAUSE HE ALWAYS COMES BY
AND VISITS US SICK KIDS.
SOMETIMES,
I CAN'T BREATHE,
OR KEEP ANY
FOOD DOWN.
BUT WHEN LITTLE DONNY
COMES BY
HE DANCES,
AND I JUST LAUGH--
( coughing )
IF I DO NOT DIE,
I WANT LITTLE DONNY
AT MY BIRTHDAY PARTY,
AND HIS BIG
PENIS TOO.
WE COULD
LAUGH A LOT,
AND THEN WE COULD
HAVE CAKE.
( coughing )
I GUESS THIS DONNY'S
IN FOR SOME TESTS.
THESE GET-A-WISH KIDS
ARE ALL THE SAME.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY
FEEL SORRY FOR THEMSELVES.
SO I JUST TRY TO SHAKE
THEM UP A LITTLE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT'S
THE MATTER WITH THIS KID.
HO HO HO HO !
HELLO, HELLO,
HELLO !
IS SOMEONE FEELING
SORRY FOR THEMSELVES ?
YOU'RE NOT
THE TITTE BROTHERS.
THE TITTE BROTHERS
COULDN'T MAKE IT.
I'M THE WORLD'S PREMIER
OUTER-FRINGE ATHLETE
AND A PUSSY'S
WORSE NIGHTMARE.
ARE YOU
A PUSSY DONNY ?
WHAT'S SO BAD
THAT YOU HAVE TO--
WHAT THE HELL
IS THAT ?
( man )
HE HAS ENORMOUS PENIS,
BUT HE'S UNAWARE OF IT.
WELL, WE'RE GONNA TURN
A NEGATIVE INTO A POSITIVE.
GET UP, DONNY !
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
GOT BETWEEN YOUR LEGS ?
YOU GOT A MAGNIFICENT
GOD-GIVEN WEAPON.
NOW SWING YOUR HIPS,
DONNY.
PUMP 'EM, PUMP 'EM !
THAT'S A TWO-FOOT
DEFLECTIVE BARRIER !
COME ON, COME ON !
WHAT ?
ATTACK HIM !
I AIN'T GOING NEAR
THAT THING.
COME ON, DONNY,
HARDER !
GET DOWN !
THERE YOU GO,
YOU DID THAT, DONNY !
AND WHEN WE WERE
DOING OUR FINALE,
SOME OF THE DANCERS NOTICED
MOVEMENT IN THE AUDITORIUM,
AND BEFORE
WE KNEW IT,
THIS YOUNG MAN DONNY,
HAD ROSE OUT OF HIS SEAT,
AND WAS IN
THE AISLES DANCING,
AND CREATING SUCH AN INCREDIBLE
VOCABULARY OF MOVEMENT,
IT WAS MUCH MORE INSPIRING
THAN THE WORK ONSTAGE.
FORTUNATELY, HE CAME
BACKSTAGE AFTER THE SHOW.
WE ASKED HIM
TO COME JOIN US.
WE'RE IN REHEARSAL
FOR A NEW PIECE
WHICH IS INSPIRED BY
DONNY'S MOVEMENT AND FREEDOM,
IT'S ASTONISHING.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THE DISEASE,
BUT IT HAS MOSTLY
TO DO WITH GENETICS,
AS OPPOSED TO SOMETHING
THAT MAY HAVE GONE WRONG
IN A DELIVERY ROOM.
THE LITTLE DONNY FOUNDATION
WAS FORMED IN 1992,
BY AN INTERNATIONAL TEAM OF
DOCTORS AND SCIENTISTS,
WHO SHARED A PASSION
FOR LITTLE DONNY'S PENIS.
SINCE THEN, MANY DISCOVERIES
HAVE BEEN MADE,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
A CURE HAS YET TO BE FOUND.
WITH THE ENZYMES WE PULLED
OUT OF LITTLE DONNY'S PENIS,
WE WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP
A ROCKET FUEL
WITH 38% INCREASED
EFFICIENCY.